how long is this gonna go on well let's
hope not too long because the Canadian
dollar now at a five-year love course
the biggest export out of Canada I think
it's i think a u.s. dollar now by see
about a dollar spot 14 now anyway let's
go back to oil here so we're below
eighty dollars for the first time in
over two years I think we're at 77 78
across all of these contracts think over
the next few months or so Brent which
the global benchmark of course it's back
below 85 84 10 last I checked we get
Brent up as well I think because the
reason I bring that up is because we're
again very close to touching this
four-year low yeah of about 83 83 25
which is I think the lowest since
November 23 2010 now the latest reason
here I guess adding to the law what's
getting to be a longer and longer list
here of reasons why investors dumping
and getting out of oil it's again Saudi
Arabia so I think a few weeks back knee
cut their official prices to Asia
they've now cut their official prices to
the north american market to the US
market here yet again it's again another
move here that's being interpreted at
the very least by the market that the
big producer Saudi is perhaps more
comfortable dealing with prices where
they are and doing this just simply to
regain market share of course they have
to contend with us producers right now
so that's the short of it as far as the
supply side is concerned now we always
also talk about demand I think we were
speaking about this yesterday that
simply no the world is not just meeting
with much much oil right now you have
the big consumers india china for
example not growing as fast as they used
to be let's listen in to marc faber
author of course the gloom boom & doom
report maybe the decline in oil prices
tells you that the global econ it's not
recovering as all the bullish analysts
think but accident actually is weakening
yes weakening but some countries and if
it from lower oil price particularly
india
and of course he sets out with a little
bit of a smirk there of course uh just
to add to this hedge funds have now cut
their long positions on oil to the
lowest in 17 months well let's talk
about supply again because how much has
shale really change the landscape here
yeah that's really changed a dynamic if
you talk about I guess pricing power of
OPEC which is responsible for forty
percent of global out book it certainly
eroded that pricing power that they have
because simply the US which is the
biggest importer obviously of oil isn't
importing as much anymore they're
getting closer to energy independence I
mentioned Saudi of course cutting prices
you look at the crude imports you as
crude imports from Saudi Arabia over the
past what four or five years we're
looking at about more or less about a
million if you can get back to the
previous chart that we just showed there
a u.s. import from Saudi Arabia uh more
or less at about a million more like a
million per day that's actually now down
to below 700,000 based on initial data
yep so here we go five years we're 22
million is basically the upper end of
this chart we're looking at 500,000 so
the draw a line at where more this
average if that's about a million and
look at where we are right now that's
about 600,000 Wow a date now the next
chart and over in the US the short of it
is really again they're producing i
guess the hyatt they had the highest
output of oil in since at least 1983
almost 9 million barrels every day and
all of this is happening as OPEC
continues to ramp up production I think
we're now at about thirty 1 million by
ounce a day and this is what is making a
lot of African oil-producing nations
very very nervous about the state of
their local economies because the u.s.
they're highly dependent on Nigeria for
example bear it there yeah I think us
actually no longer importing oil from
Nigeria anymore yeah I mean it's also a
big part because when you build your
economy around one industry it's it's
you know it's just two sides at the same
coin really you know when things are
good you know you're literally sipping
champagne mixed your oil field but again
yeah you look what's happening now and
you know it you know it's for the lack
of a better word it's a
pricing it's a price war what's
happening between the big oil producers
and against the next big one is OPEC
meeting at the end of this month 23rd
will they agree on production cuts